هل يقوم فريقك في ووهان الذي
يبحث الآن في أصول
فيروس كورونا ، هل هم في وضع
يسمح
لهم بتقديم
معلومات أفضل أو إعادة معلومات أفضل
ستساعدك على
وضع نوع من
الخطط الموثوقة بشأن هذه الأشياء الجديدة  المتغيرات وما هي
المعلومات التي لدينا
من الفريق في ووهان ، لذا نعم
هذا سؤال جيد جدًا ، فقد خرج الفريق في
gohan اليوم
من الحجر الصحي
وبدأوا العمل ، وكانت
هذه هي الرسالة الأولى التي تلقيناها
هذا الصباح وبدأنا العمل
و  بمجرد
حصولنا على المعلومات التي سنشاركها ،
نأمل أن نتعلم
المزيد ونعم بالفعل أنها مرتبطة
أيضًا بالجينات الوراثية للفيروس
ولكن من المثير للاهتمام للغاية أن
نتذكر أن
هذا الفيروس لا يستضيفه البشر فقط
كما نحن  تعرف وهي أيضًا
تحب الحيوانات الأخرى وهذه الحالة الصحية
تجعل الأمر أكثر تعقيدًا ،
وبالتالي
فهي معركة صعبة
وهي معركة لا يزال أمامنا عدة أشهر إن
لم يكن
سنوات من الفوز بها لفترة وجيزة.
هل ترى أن هناك حالات كانت هناك
حالات
وأوبئة في الماضي في تاريخنا
حيث ساءت الأمور قبل أن
تتحسن شخصيًا ، آمل أن يقرر هذا الفيروس
العودة إلى أي مكان
ولكن إذا لم يكن علينا أن نكون  صبور
وهذا هو المكان
الذي نرى فيه التوتر حقًا ، فنحن نرى
سبل
العيش والاقتصاد والإحباط الذي يشعر به
الناس كما تعلمون أننا جميعًا لدينا
ما يكفي
ولكن علينا حماية بعضنا البعض ،
إنها معركة ضد
الفيروس وليس ضد بعضنا البعض